understanding the classic holds found in
ikea
when people are trying to understand
aikido they often use modern martial
arts or sport martial arts as their
example of
what you should be doing in a fight
situation so when they see the things
that i'm kidding they look really really
strange
in aikido we have lots of hand holding
techniques like a
top a single side hand grab or a cross
hand grab two hand grab
both hands grab and if you come from a
situation
of fighting as a youth on the playground
or in a sports situation these holds
don't seem very practical to you
you're used to seeing things like a bear
hug
perhaps a waist lock and of course those
things can be done from the front or the
back
you'd have bear hugs and waist locks
this gives me good body control so i
have a lot of body control over my gives
me the ability to lift mic and throw
them take them where i want or hold them
so my friends can hit him
you also see things like the rear naked
choke classic choke like this you don't
see this kind of choking aikido
um so when you're used to seeing those
kind of things and you see what we have
in aikido
it doesn't seem to make any sense and
then further if you go to practice those
things in sport martial arts
you see that the sport martial arts
holds are much better bear hugs are much
better than what you see in aikido
and the reason that we don't use those
in aikido is very simple
in aikido we're always dealing with
weapon orientations we're always dealing
with someone else who's armed or when
i'm armed so for example if i were in a
bear hunt situation here with mike
and all i do is i grab him now i do have
good body control the problem is i don't
have any control over mike's hands
so if as an armed summer i might quickly
draw a weapon
he can stab me right make sure i stay
here now it's just a matter of me
bleeding out as soon as i've lost enough
blood that i can't hold them anymore
that's the end of it right
mike could also cut my arms from here if
i came in for a waste lock this is even
worse for me right
i have a lot of body control but i have
no appendage control because i can't
control mike's hands he can cut me
stab me this is bad for me which means i
would have to control his hands if i
don't want to get hurt in this position
a rear naked choke even worse right so
from this position here
mike's hands are completely free he can
stab me it's a matter of
do i pass out before do i bleed out
before mike passes out
so in a modern sport situation where you
don't have a weapon you can't see
why we have the kinds of holes we have
in aikido
and other holes that control the body
better maybe seem like a better idea
now the classic holes we have in aikido
are easily illustrated again when we
look at a weapon so mike has a weapon
out
and i want to control mike so i want to
grab his wrist and control it and i can
work from here so this would be
dory or or a great grab like moral
theory where i'm really getting in and
getting some control keeping control of
his hand
our choke that we use in aikido is uh
which does this you see i
choke him here but i account for the
other hand that has the weapon
in it right if from this situation say
michael's be able to get his hand
in and switch weapon hands i could
quickly slide back and do
share a real thing where i have both of
his hands checked now shiro royaltori
without a weapon might seem like a silly
grab
but when the weapon's in the hand you
can see it's an ideal grab because now
i'm controlling the weapon so mike can't
stab me with it
it's really important when you're
studying niketa to understand where the
techniques come from
they don't come from modern ideals of
fighting they don't come from a
one-on-one
unarmed situation like you would see in
sport fight they come from weapons
conflict where
i'm dealing with multiple attackers who
are probably armed and if i
have the ability i'm going to be armed
that's why he's going to be grabbing me
to control me
because i need to be armed understanding
the classic holds performed in ikea